seems like if your world is being
invaded by monsters then the least of
your worries would be the Taco Tuesday
hoax and definitely not to the point of
obsession by the local crawl rider one
question if this is a brother and sister
playing together with their toys are
they imagining this damage to some
certain extent or are they actually
physically causing buildings of Lego
glass to spontaneously explode wait
president business didn't even get in
trouble for his antics in the last movie
we fought them off but they kept
returning hey why not make a movie about
that that sounds bonkers and always
accompanied by cheap pop listen
character from the first lego movie you
did not get to be upset about catchy pop
music where's Batman he's off having a
separate standalone adventure Wow even
in the mind of a child
Batman is having his own standalone
adventure that's showing some discipline
and Metta joking my child mine could
never comprehend I'd have found a way to
put three Batman's in my Justice League
mission to make my sister cry Mad Max
Lego Road maybe this is somehow the
point but doesn't Emmet putting on
headphones make this coffee commute 100
times more dangerous and deadly to him
don't you need your ears and Apocalypse
Bird these rough dudes are fighting over
the best James Bond which is hilarious
but one of them says Sean Connery and
then another says Daniel Craig then a
third guy comes in and says fraud you're
Moore and even though there are only
three fighters Pierce Brosnan and George
Lazenby get thrown into the argument and
all I have to say is you cannot pick
more than one and besides the best bond
ever was interest elbow the super long
list of rattled off silly names and the
gag about ending on a totally normal
name have both been done to death prior
to this movie once I was a rebel
fighting for a righteous cause will be
within a child's imagination narration
child imagination and I hate to say it
but if you look up overstaying your
welcome and modern dictionaries it's a
picture of Lego Batman hang on movie has
way more time for this than I do
like what you got invaded by aliens for
five years you've never seen anything
like any of that why would you say this
right now about this thing I know this
is supposed to be same old limit and all
and it's funny that he's putting all the
non-essential gear on this car but
didn't he become a master builder at the
end of the first movie wouldn't this
life-and-death situation inspire more
lethal assembly the movie rips off the
fast to furious and the transformer
movies in one skyscraper bull scene and
that's almost impressive enough to
warrant a sin removed I said almost good
thing you're a master builder and that
house was made of Legos right I mean can
you imagine wait why are you saying you
do Yuna Kitty's been so angry for this
whole movie I barely remember the
character who was so sweet that she
suppressed her rage in the first movie
steals my daily mantra and I am suddenly
shook not so sure I can't still send the
movie for stealing my thoughts pot still
is just me or is the meta humor dialed
up 25% more than the first movie how
many movies have they made about you
because there are like nine about me
look measuring contest so you fought and
masterbuilt and kicked butt and then the
hapless male was the leader movie where
sinning would be excellent at cinemasins
and that Emmet isn't changing with the
times and lacks the killer instinct and
in general just isn't tough enough how
is Emmet surprised and/or crushed by
this realization how does he not already
know his own lack of toughness during
this moment where the movie reminds you
that kids are coming up with the plot
Finn informs his sister that he's in the
middle of a story with time travel and
plot twists but how are they using the
same characters in competing storylines
yeah a total Hufflepuff using Hufflepuff
as an insult
hilarious except they were just mad at
him for the superfriends getting
kidnapped by an alien robot look they're
unwilling to try and help rescue those
people let's move e wants everyone to be
anti Emmett and in the surface of that
it makes everyone anti logic for a bit
hang on you frogs
planning discount fruit we're going save
Lucy its space though man even if I
believe you know enough about space
travel to build a spacecraft that works
how the fuck do you know where to go
this star system is kind of ripping off
those coexist bumper stickers they are
prisoners though right why are you just
letting them roam the ship free to cram
into your personal space here and ruin
your majestic landing are we in a
musical I sure hope not
o me sideways this is where Emmet and
star-lord combined with a guy Chris
Pratt played and passengers Jim Preston
for those of you who haven't seen it 20
times like me - totally Pratt this movie
to death I'm surprised I'm not hearing
come and get your love right now
underscored by that John Williams
Jurassic Park score that that piece of
fallen world put in a minor key to try
and be dark and edgy let me guess this
spaceman X marketing is actually going
to turn out evil much like ego did in
guardians of the galaxy - and they're
going through a stayer gate but this guy
isn't voiced by Kurt Russell which is
disappointing in a movie as meta as this
I don't know what the sin is really
other than the scene reminds me of
guardians of the galaxy - and Stargate
and when Chris Pratt does the voice of
this character I think he's doing a Kurt
Russell impersonation but here's us
until I figure out how I feel save your
life this movie X maka does every three
minutes it's borderline harassment we
won't play the music during the sin but
to sin news Motley Crue no one will be
seated during the Yellow Submarine
portion of the movie haha these Raptors
talk and extremely worn out office
worker cliches how delightful the
isolation intense and I think if this
household just had cats
dude man here would have been rescued
from under the dryer in mere minutes
also Holly in my house growing up we
clean weekly my brother and I both had
jobs and if we missed something this
close to the edge of the under the dryer
area we'd have gotten spanked literally
no one in this family even looks under
the dryer for ages
no one's tied down this bed man forever
reference I feel like somebody could say
reference through half of this movie and
it would be apt I said general mayhem
believes this I like to talk about
feelings and how we're in love but can't
be together
wholly the references in this film are
beginning to sound like something out of
ethic movie or in this case and dare I
say it vampire suck and I like this
movie way more than those but what a
horrible feeling
get off em every as wellis now I don't
think Shawn this movie is so filled with
preferences when I saw Bruce Willis in
the hot tub with something retinas hand
I thought it was some vague color at
night parody hmm movie has all the
heroes doubting Lucy's toughness because
her hair got pretty and that is
definitely racist it's kind of funny to
me that since this is Bianca in control
of the narrative
she knows the entire backstory that Finn
gave wyldstyle and it's acting out the
characters with no discernible
difference I plan that I get the sense
that these Raptors were a lot more
hilarious on paper than they actually
are in the film why didn't you come back
for us not that it's any of my business
but where the hell was Superman hiding
Green Lantern just now I can't play the
music but this song goes this song's
gonna get stuck inside your this song's
gonna get stuck inside your head and
that's not as funny as the movie thinks
it is while still being all the annoying
that the movie knows it is her jumping
up to the top bar the EQ meters is
pretty clever she'll be giving us a tall
man probably not funny but are these
vents soundproof don't make a call to
girlfriend joke don't make a college
girlfriend joke there may be harping on
this too much but since Emmett and Rex
are in fins story how does Bianca
integrate wild style into it from the
story she's making up the behind the
scenes story is that the brother and
sister aren't getting along correct that
man is a permanent bat chiller I'm so
confused by the brainwashing song does
it wear off if wears off why hasn't he D
sparkled er don't the white cape how can
you brainwash everyone as a plot device
to let Emmett wyldstyle save the day but
then pretend it didn't take with Batman
so he could be a plot device that stalls
the proceedings to give time to Emmett
involve stop and yes they eventually say
no one was brainwashed but everyone was
acting pretty fuckin brainwashed so I
reject that oh great more singing
right on time the decision to make Lego
a movie - more of a musical was about as
good a choice as the milk was in
anchorman
so what you did Superman I don't care
but like you're clearly just confused
missus epic Rap Battles now I used to
entice let's get him worse oh this biank
I know who Adam West is just just trust
me nope they all died this animation is
a lie this is a projected building
schematic it cannot do the things and
narrates on the fly Bruce Willis cameo
gag was meant at first kind of funny
when wyldstyle bumped into him and at
this point I'm just ready to say it's
worn me down once in removed but I had
that sin right back for Bruce Willis
trying harder in this animated movie
that he has for either of the last two
die hard films if you knew wyldstyle was
here the whole time why didn't you just
go ahead and kill her yes
acknowledgement that this is all playing
out in a child's brain so this movie for
making me sin children's brains how
though did Rex know that Wonder Woman's
invisible plane was going to be here
when he jumped also wow I love this gag
I never pegged Wonder Woman as someone
who would show up this late to a wedding
ceremony especially since she's one of
the many characters who've been
brainwashed since coming to the sistar
system was your blouse oh and visible
too I like you the way you were boy
first star-lord then it's Chris Pratt
intentionally playing characters that
sabotage the heroes plan at the last
minute fin drop dammit and is
frantically looking for him but
considering that this is the cleanest
damn floor ever and there are several
places he could have fallen under why
didn't he check under everywhere
including the dryer he seems to be
focusing his entire search in the middle
of the room and then I saw a way to undo
Christ he's been narrating this reveal
flashback for forever this time travels
stuffs always kind of confusing it's
best just to go with it I will not what
exactly is our mom again it's apparently
something that Bianca knew would happen
if she stole Vince toys and he'd be
angry about it causing destruction that
would lead to their mom banning them
from playing Legos and yet she did it
anyway because despite the ridiculous
wealth of knowledge and pop-culture
references in her head she's still just
nine years old and does stupid she knows
we'll get her into trouble I think every
movie could use more Maya Rudolph but
making her grow through her Sideshow Bob
steps on rakes impersonation it's not
the best representation of her talent
and this might be the fakest Photoshop
of a good time since that time I
inserted myself into a 1969 Woodstock
photo wearing a cap shirt and an iPhone
hanging out of my back pocket
although interesting though the gap
opened a mere three
days after the Woodstock Festival but it
was still a glaring anachronism ah no no
no no no no no no no she didn't hear as
these Legos get put in Rubbermaid bins
and stored away I'm left to wonder if
this movie has anything to say that
hasn't already been better covered by
one of the Toy Story movies movie bar
was the obviously fake ending from vice
oh man Finn is in such trouble for this
act of kindness mom said the Legos go in
storage so you're all abridge do you
know this dude also a classic reversal
of the villain tells the hero is playing
cliche nyan cat I would be willing to
accept its explanation of the entire
Rick's Emmett story if several things in
this movie didn't happen that contradict
it we have this scene where Finn
explains he's working through a
storyline involving time travel and
there's this shot of the Lego spaceship
that the movie makes a point to show
Finn controlling with a string sure I
can allow a fantasy reality and
metaphorical exist in a movie but it's
difficult when those things undermine
established facts like a movie to man
and the downsizing you're never going to
turn out like me which means I'm never
gonna exist a space time continuum
allows Rex to realize this before
actually disappearing which is an
awesome gift the space-time continuum
rarely grants well I told him never to
play Legos again but as long as they're
happy I guess I'll allow it
there's no way they'll ever fight again
I'm such a good mom
I missed the gimme putt for birdie on
seven how is president business still
facing no consequences for his actions
in the first movie this movie has over
13 minutes of credits he hikes
come play with us Danny can you do that
for me well yeah I can try do or do not
there is no try
must go faster do you like eating in
here no no the truth I don't think I've
ever been in this room before but anger
was the key to my $40 I pay on you but
you're broken I don't want to play with
you anymore